hello everyone and welcome to another
most excellent game from the 2019 isle
of man chess tournament it's a game from
Round three a game I wanted to show but
didn't as it didn't affect the standings
all that much but as Vincent Kaymer the
German Bobby Fischer as we like to call
him when his Grandmaster title he won
his two grandmasters norm grandmaster
norms over a year ago I believe in then
it took him a real long time to get his
third grandmaster norm but everyone knew
that he definitely deserves it if you if
you've been following this channel for
at least a year you know that he won the
grant a 2018 the third edition of the
Greinke open tournament with eight out
of nine points that's really insane in
front of many I believe there were like
almost 50 grand masters at that
tournament and he wanted in front of all
of them that seven wins and two draws so
without a single loss that was truly an
impressive result and it's not you know
not all that hard to believe as he is a
very talented player and he is trained
by none other than a pitcher like oh so
here he faces Russian Grand Master
assonance ugarov and for those of you
who again have been following this
channel for quite some time maybe
remember we've shown again from the 2010
chess olympiad in hunting man Sisk were
a suger of defeated Magnus cross and in
a miniature really a really wonderful
game also I will put a link to that game
in the description below it will be the
first thing you see so feel free to
check it out if you're interested you
know it's not every day that someone
beats Crossan in a miniature so getting
back to this game Vincent with the white
pieces open the width d4 and okay we
have g6 the modern defense c4 we've
disrupted g7
Knight to f3 with d6 and now g3 Vincent
prefers to fianchetto the light square
Bishop with c5 and d5 and here we have
b5 a similar idea as you would see for
example in the Banco gambit well you
will push b5 and then if white captures
you can also play a six and someone
gives some points for rapid development
C capture some b5 is played vincent
accepts the pawn in the now Queen to a5
width check we have Knights to c3
this position has been reached before
only there is one game for Bishop to d7
was played here we have a six trying to
give up one more pawn and it is as a
move seven that we have a completely new
game so here how here's how Vincent
deals with it he doesn't like the idea
of grabbing another pawn so he advances
it b6 and now the problem is black will
not be able to capture here twice
because the white will be left with a
very nice pass pawn on d6 for example if
you now capture and trade everything
here check check check
Russia blocks the Queen nicely guards
the rook you have to move away with her
queen now rugby 1 you are threatening b7
so black will probably play Bishop to e7
but all in all you gets to keep your
past b6 pawn so here sugar has to react
to this he captures the b61 in the now
night to d2 clearing this diagonal for
his light square bishop and also
preparing to bring the knight to the c-4
as it it's a very nice outpost for the
night with Knight this Knight to f6 and
Bishop to g2 both players castle with
castles castles and Knight B to d7 will
be three by Vincent also preparing to
theater his dark squared Bishop as well
and now a5 with nice to see four now
with an attack on the Queen Queen to a6
and now Knight to a4 not allowing this
point to be pushed any further and also
preparing Bishop to b2
if black makes a discovery with the
nitrogen Bishop to b2 can always be
played so nice the g4 now the bishop
opens an attack towards the rook with
Bishop to b2 blocking and now comes the
Bishop captures and b2 we have night a
capture Sun b2 and now comes Knight G
back to e5 Vincent's trades once we have
Knight captures on e5 with Knight
captures on e5 ended now f4 linson so
far doing a great job keeping wax pieces
at bay
Knight back to d7 and the black still
has to figure out how is this night
getting into the game and also more
importantly how is this light squared
Bishop getting into the game we've
looked the c1 by Vincent a normal
developing move and now nights the b6
and a for now again not allowing black
to make any breakthroughs with a 4 so a
4 by white and Bishop to g4 now black is
able to develop his bishop now with an
attack on the upon
you cannot leave for as white wants to
play e4 also you're just threatening to
capture it with just Bishop capture
Sunday - I need to so look - f2 and odd
square for the rook but it's only
temporarily you want to play h3 push the
bishop back and then you'll push efore
and your rook comes alive so it's not a
problem
rook F to c8 now preparing to push c4
and here h3 as planned with Russia back
to d7 again are not allowing blacks to
develop and now finally efore and here
black really wants to push c4 but here
it's not so clear if you can do it right
away for example if c4 here B captures
on c4 you have to find rook a to b8 if
you don't find that if you just continue
the game you might as well lose the game
right away because if Knight captures
you're just gonna play rook captures
rook captures and Bishop back to f1 wins
the game on the spot so c4 is a nice
move but it's it's a really complicated
move so Queen the a7 getting the Queen
away from this diagonal and also putting
the Queen on this diagonal that the King
occupies might come in handy in the
future with f5 Vincent as now all of
black's pieces are stuck pretty much on
the Queen side starts an attack on the
Kings side with f6 and now comes h4 came
to g7 and now g4 here Vincent prepares
g5 we have looked at f8 if DF file opens
then you want to have your looks on the
F file and now g5 so here a lot of
tension here and the position is
definitely going to open up with rook to
f7 by a sugar of preparing to bring the
other rook into the game and now comes
Knight to b3 preparing to bring the
knight deeper into the attack via Knight
to a4 will c4 finally and a here Vincent
ignores black he goes in Knight to f4
seek a person b3 Queen captures on b3
and now Knight captures on a4 and now
what do you play here feel free to pause
the video even and try to find an
interesting move for white while I give
you a couple of seconds now for those of
you who found an interesting move
Vincent here played Queen to g3 I when I
saw this position when I first saw it I
said yeah 996 is what you play here and
the knight and 90
is the strongest more recommended by the
engine although even though I saw it
right away
it's one thing to see it is the other
thing to actually play it because it
does require a whole other calculation
because of course if nightsticks check
and the sub characters now of course the
knight is unguarded here so if you
continue you just captured it bishop now
the rook is under attack and now if you
move the rook you're just gonna lose the
knight so here you have to play Knight
c5 with an attack on the Queen and only
after rook captures and Queen captures
do capture on f7 and you end up this
variation being up a polite square
bishop although for the moment that
Bishop isn't doing all that much and
black has a passed pawn ready to be
pushed so although you are better here
is why it's not easy to go into
something like this if you're not all
too sure and don't have all that much
time to calculate on the other hand
after night the e6 check you don't have
to capture if you go King to g8 then the
variation becomes really interesting
because now you get rook the c7
attacking the Queen and the bishop but
you are not winning a piece here because
black has Queen to b6 now attacking the
Queen here and now you have to find that
after Queen captures Knight captures
this defends the bishop and now you have
looked the b7 attacking the knight and
if you the knight moves you're gonna
finally win the bishop so the only way
to defend the knight is rook the a6 and
now of course you have to find the Ruby
8 check the night covers g7 so you
cannot go there you have to block with
Knights the c8 and now finally rook the
c2 wins you the game as now you don't
really have any other moves you don't
have a weight to guard the night here
the capturing doesn't help you because
then the rook on f7 also gets under
attack so Knights the e6 check does win
here but it's it requires a lot of
calculation which you know if there's a
simple move that's also nice you might
want to go with that one so Vincent goes
for Queen to g3 with F captures on g5
now for black with Queen captures on g5
now the Queen King are nicely on the
same same file and now rook a to f8 so
what do you play here Vincent brings the
other look into the attack first
rook seed f1 and now black finds a very
interesting tactic here silver plays
the shop characters on f5 and it's it's
it's sort of not a peace sacrifice
because Vincent captures it
we have rook captures an f5 with an
attack on the Queen and now it's it
becomes obvious what the idea was after
the Queen was you just recapture your
piece back because the rook on f2 is
pinned the rook will not be able to
recapture so once again and this one is
really a tricky one
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find the best move for white in
this position well I'll give you a
couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it Vincent played
night the e6 check and it's a beautiful
move that wins the game but there is
also another one if any of you saw pink
the h1 it's then just you know hats off
to you you are a true true you know
gentlemen of the game
because here you cannot capture the the
Queen and you cannot recapture the piece
because the in fact is no longer pinned
and it's just well just very funny how
just works the rook captures and g5 it I
mean what else are you gonna play now
you play Knight to the e6 check and now
if King to g8 or h8 for example you just
get made it rook captures and f8 is made
and if you start running away with the
King over to the h6 then you get H
captures and g5 with check King gauge 5
and now rook captures on f8 and White
has two rooks a bishop and in the
monster night here on e6 for a queen and
an oddly placed knight on a on a four
it's you know it's very hard for black
to survive this ideas like rook F for
Bishop f3 checkmate are coming now black
could prevent this mate but he will have
to suffer severe material loss so King
to h1 really just just a very exciting
move or or King h2 for that matter but
ok nice the e6 also wins and it comes
with a similar idea King to g8 and now
Knight after Sun f8 so it still is a
Queen sacrifice rook captures and g5 and
H captures and g5 we have Queen III by
still Grove and now King to h1 so it's a
bit of a same idea only a different move
order Knight the c5 now sugar of tries
to bring his knight back into the game
but not Knight captures on h7 another
great idea by by Kaymer if the knight is
captured then it's a quick mate since
the pond
the eighty-six square you just have to
go back check you go back and the roof
to f7 will be made
so after night captures on h7 we have
Knight to d7 trying to get the knight
back into the game but now Knight the f8
here Kaymer wants the trade nights and
then just have two rooks and the Bishop
against the Queen this would be
completely winning so of course you get
of declines the trade we have night to
c5 and mountain Knight captures on g6
Queen captures on g5 and now the easiest
path the victory rook to f8 check you
just win back the Queen King to g7 dear
rook checks on f7 check you have to
capture here and now rook the g8 with
check white is just up so much material
then he can afford to do this King
captures on f7 and now rook captures
back the Queen so recap for some g5 King
to f6 attacking the rook and now rook
the h5 so black still has some contra
plate with the past a pawn but it will
be very difficult
Sugar Grove starts pushing it with a 4
brush up to F 1 preparing Bishop to c4
so you guard the a2 square and now
Knight to e4 King to g2 and now tonight
the c3 guarding the a2 square but it's
not a problem with Bishop to c4 and now
a3 with King to f3 and the now comes
East 6 hoping to get the Bishop away
from this diagonal but it it doesn't
work with D captures an e6 d5 attacking
the bishop and here vincent played rook
captures on d5 the idea being that if
you capture the ship captures you
control your past pawn and also the
queening square so this point is never
crossing the a2 square and you are just
going to bring your King over here for
example and then push the point to
victory and if after real characters on
d5 you played this move you eliminate a
white passed pawn than just a room d3
check opens up a discovery you win this
guy here and it's again game over
so after real captures and d5 sugar
played a 2 and the now Vinson just
played rope to a5
guarding the da to pawn you can just
push play for example Bishop captures an
a2 then the next move and it's it's a
game over black has no counter play
whatsoever yeah after this rook de 5
move sugar resigned the game and oh and
an excellent victory for Vincent
timer in this aisle of Manchester namond
where he won his third Grand Master norm
and on the next first of the month he
will be he already has his grand master
title but I believe it will be
officially GM instead of I am on all the
websites as of first of the next month
yeah yeah that's really amazing stuff so
I'm very happy for for young Vince after
all of his achievements it's you know
time to put those two letters GM
officially next to his name and like I
said if you're interested in sugar of
miniature against Magnus cross and it
will be the first link in the
description below so do check it out if
you have some additional time I would
also like to thank Joshua Witter and the
James Briscoe for your contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos you're thinking
for watching and I will see you soon
I will cover a few more games from the
isle of man chess tournament the games
that I didn't have the time to cover
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and we are about to start a
vote for our next big saga so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day